Russia's military is stepping up its
so-called partial mobilization for its
war on Ukraine the defense minister says
half a million reservists will be
recalled Ukraine's Army is pushing
farther into russian-controlled areas
and recapturing more territory Charlie
dagger the reports from one area where
Ukrainian troops are on the march in the
Russian army is falling back
this morning we crossed over into the
Don bass region in eastern Ukraine as
far as President Putin is concerned
we're now walking on Russian soil but
you can see the Ukrainian flag flying
behind me there's a heavy Ukrainian
military presence here on the way here a
couple of Ukrainian fighter jets flew
overhead now this town is full of
residents it's a fully functioning town
it's on the way to Lehman that is the
Strategic town in the East that the
Ukrainian forces liberated a few days
ago we understand they're making even
more advances in that region Russian
troops on the retreat not just there but
south of here in Curson Ukrainian forces
are pushing back Russians there too so
Russians have been losing territory ever
since President Putin's announcement
what makes it concerning is when
President Putin annexed these areas he
said that he would use everything at his
disposal to defend what he called now
Russia territory he hinted at the use of
nuclear weapons now today it's the turn
for the Russian Parliament the Duma to
ratify that annexation of course it's
expected to sail through for CBS
mornings Charlie dagada prokowsk Ukraine